from a strictly strategic perspective, Joe
Biden should pick Elizabeth.
Warren, as his vice president, I'm going to
make the case for that now.
Joe Biden already committed to choosing a
woman to be his running mate.
Joe Biden has been asked more and more lately
to select a woman of color.
We saw Senator Amy Klobuchar remove her name
from consideration, saying Joe should really
pick a woman of color now.
I think part of it was Amy Klobuchar was wrapped
up in the whole Derrick Schavan fiasco.
We won't revisit that now, but I think that
played a role.
But in any case, Amy Klobuchar dropping out
and saying Joe should really pick a woman
of color rather than me.
And that would be powerful in its own way.
But from a merely strategic point of view,
I believe Elizabeth Warren actually makes
the most sense.
If you ballons name recognition, how progressive
the candidates being considered are and the
effect that the choice would have on the electorate
based on polling that we have.
Elizabeth Warren seems like clearly the right
selection to me.
Now, there's a lot of talk about Kamala Harris,
a black woman, current senator from California.
Harris's identity would be very powerful.
The first woman V.P. also being a black woman.
There's no doubt that would be very powerful.
The problem is Kamala Harris is prosecutorial
record as attorney general in the state of
California.
And that is not likely to pull in disaffected
Bernie voters.
It's not likely to appeal to the progressive
wing of the Democratic Party.
I don't believe that the disaffected Bernie
voters are like this huge portion of the electorate.
But this could be a very close race, particularly
in some key states.
And seeing a prosecutor of the failed war
on drugs being Joe Biden's V.P. will do more
damage, I believe, than the benefit of Kamala
Harris is identity as a woman of color.
You then seem names seen names thrown around
like Stacey Abrams.
Now, I like Stacey Abrams.
She was a Georgia state rep.
She ran for governor in Georgia in 2018.
I don't believe she has the experience nor
the name recognition to really help Joe Biden
very much.
I don't actually believe she's a top candidate
right now.
I think there's a very small chance that she
is selected.
Joe Biden is also reportedly considering Val
Demings, a black congresswoman from Florida
and Michigan Governor Aggression Wittmer from
Michigan.
And there's an interesting case to be made
for either of them.
But it seems very clear to me that Elizabeth
Warren, after Bernie, is the next most progressive
candidate that was in the running in the Democratic
primary in 2020.
And she has the name recognition and she has
some important accomplishments to her name,
including the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau.
When you talk about structural reform and
you look at Kamala Harris versus Elizabeth
Warren, Warren is much closer to being the
structural change candidate than Harris.
There's no doubt that Bernie was these structural
change candidate.
No question about it.
But after Bernie, it's Warren.
It's not Harris.
And I think that that will have an appeal
that the other candidates will not have to
make this point a different way.
Warren would mobilize the group that Biden
needs.
Biden has 92 percent support from black voters.
Biden is not as strong with the most progressive
piece of the electorate.
That's who Warren helps the most with.
And I don't think she hurts him with black
voters at all.
And in fact, there's a morning consult poll
that shows that Warren would bring in more
black voters than even Harris would.
And even then, Stacey Abrams would, which
are very, very interesting and and results
that reinforce Warren being the strongest
pick.
So, in short, to put it very simply, Warren
is the most progressive, highly known person
being considered.
And in the polls, she helps Biden the most,
not only with the most progressive voters,
but also with black voters.
So that's who I would go with.
Now, that being said, there are all sorts
of ancillary reasons to focus in on a woman
of color instead of a white woman.
I don't deny that for a second.
There's also a case that Biden that Warren,
rather, would be a strong cabinet pick for
Biden if she weren't V.P. and she could be
very strong as treasury secretary, secretary
of commerce, other possibilities.
But vice president would be powerful and it
would make an impact right away.
Biden is reportedly going to make his choice
around August 1st.
So we will see who it is.
One one just other argument against Elizabeth
Warren that I've seen, which is not a not
a crazy one, is the argument that Warren is
more valuable in the Senate and that if she
leaves sometimes in Massachusetts in these
special elections, we elect Republicans to
the Senate.
We saw it with Scott Brown.
This is not a seat we can afford to lose when
we are looking to take control of the Senate
in the fall.
I don't know if it will happen.
It's an uphill battle so that that would be
an argument against Elizabeth.
But it would be great to watch her destroy
Mike Pence in those debates, wouldn't it?
So my choice is Elizabeth Warren.
I
want to hear from you.